well the first day of school can be a
little nerve-wracking for kids but
having something to give the teacher can
give them a confidence boost and that's
something they might need las vegas
now's design expert brooke fritz from
clover and stem is here with some ideas
and this is a kind of a nerve-wracking
time for kids and parents
it is a nerve-wracking time i remember
my kids being nervous to go to school i
was scared to school go to school in
college so i have gathered some ideas
for you to kind of ease that nervousness
for them some fun ways to bring
joy into the going back to school i love
this idea and it's just a nice way to
break the ice totally totally so um
so i have come up with a back-to-school
dinner something you could do with your
family in the evenings before school
starts or the first week of school and
have it be a themed dinner
and
i usually pick a
an inspirational word or quote something
that will inspire my kids to do better
and to be better and so for this um
one is going to all be about kindness
how the world needs kindness right now
don't we all need kindness a lot more of
it
so uh to make this
creative and fun we have found some cute
apple plates and we paired it up with a
chalkboard
like placemat
and then we took our crayons that we had
dumped out and put in on our pencil
pouches and we just cut out those little
pencils or the crayon boxes i love the
silverware in there something fun gives
it a little bit of color then we also
did
cute little sodas and put a tag on it
and said you got this you'll crush it i
love this i love that it's just the
design of it in general yes which makes
you the design expert all right so we've
got about a minute left tell us what
else we can do what else we need to do
okay when your kids come home from
school have a fun treat ready for them
and tell them hey
tell me all about it tell me about your
day and have some cute treats for them
and on one thing that i'm super excited
to share with this crumble cookie has
partnered up with us and they want to
give two lucky classes uh crumble
cookies for their entire class oh wow so
if you go to uh clover and stem
and there will be more details on there
and you could win some delicious cookies
for the entire class they'll make back
to school a little bit more exciting for
everybody very popular person walking in
the class right for sure brooke it is
always great having you with us thanks
so much our kids went to preschool
together yes how old are how old is
yours now 25 yeah yeah makes us feel a
little older i know
old but cool yeah right
it's okay y'all look great y'all